president's homeland security secretary
tells us immigrants in the daca program
need to follow the law Christian Nielsen
testifies this morning at the Senate
Judiciary Committee she was in the Oval
Office during last week's impassioned
White House meeting on daca we asked
secretary Nielsen about that meeting and
the president's views on immigration the
president made a broad characterization
when he talked about people who came
from Haiti and African countries versus
people from Norway so why is he making
broad characterizations about people who
come from those countries when you're
saying US policies trying to move away
from broad characterizations and move
towards people I think the context of
that conversation there were so much
covered in that meeting but part of the
conversation was really focused on this
merit-based concept so he had just met
with the Prime Minister of Norway was
very impressed with what she told him
about successes that Norway has
experienced so he was just using that as
an example of a place that accepts
immigrants in part based on merit let me
ask you about your testimony on Tuesday
Senator Durbin who was in this oval
office meeting about which there has
been so much discussion is going to be
there what if he asks you whether you
agree with his representation of the
meeting I have no problem repeating what
I've said I just don't I don't that's I
don't that's not a word that I remember
being used
it was very impassioned people on all
sides feel very strongly about this
issue frankly as well as they should
there were a lot of conversations
happening at the same time that's not a
particular phrase that I heard let me
ask you about the deferred action for
childhood arrivals there's a chance that
that might not get worked out based on
the way things seem to be going I hope
if it's not what does the immigration
customs and enforcement agency do with
these kids who are here it's not going
to be a priority of the Immigration and
Customs Enforcement to prioritize their
remove
I've said that before that's not the
that's not the policy of DHS so if this
doesn't get worked out and I am a
dreamer the way I'm supposed to read
what you just said is this is not going
to be a priority of Vice if you are a
daca that's compliant with your
registration meaning you haven't
committed a crime and you in fact are
registered you're not priority of
enforcement for ice should the program
end and is that in perpetuity that'll be
in perpetuity but of course that means
you can't commit a crime sure and we
will enforce the law in our next hour
secretary Nielsen reveals highlights of
a new report showing who is being
charged with terrorism and where they
come from that's ahead on CBS this
morning